oh man I got your wrecked some scarf on
I put my scarf on um you know you gotta
enjoy the wins I I just watched a wreck
some win we're top of the league
um we're in first place and that feels
good I know that's I know this isn't a
wrexham podcast but you know you gotta
you gotta do it number one it's good it
feels good to be in first place you know
what else feels good uh watching this
episode maybe my favorite episode thus
far during the re-watch really truly up
there for me too it's it's up there
probably one of my top 10
episodes of all time it's like I say
that a lot but um
yeah you want to do us an intro yeah
um sure uh we're getting right into the
episode none of you are coming in hot
yeah well let's see no let's get the
fans what they want they want to hear us
talk about the episode this is a good
one to talk about we're in the process
of working on the show so it feels like
it's very present in our minds how
things happen and and how they happened
to just get into it well I mean unless
we want to give some people some context
to where we are We Are One Day Out
from production on season 16. tomorrow
baby in Philadelphia we start filming
tomorrow
and we're finishing things up
um behind on a few things but no more
than other Seasons we usually have one
script or two that we're like okay we're
gonna be working on those in our trailer
that's right that's right we got it
there that's where we're at it's fun to
watch an episode like this though
because gets me excited to act
it's a good like
uh they can feel like this we're doing
something right great very inspiring
very inspiring it's very inspiring let's
tell the audience what the episode's
about so uh season five episode two is
what we're discussing today the gang
hits the road it aired on September 24th
2009 was written by Charlie and Glenn
and directed by Fred Savage the gang
tries to expand the Horizons by going on
a road trip to the Grand Canyon but they
hit a few speed bumps along the way
oh yeah more than a few right yeah
Charlie I remember writing this episode
with you uh it was the first year we
were in these offices on the fox lot
however we were one floor down from here
we're on the fourth floor we were on the
third floor we wrote that we were in the
exact office below the office that we've
been writing this entire season from and
as all the the creeps can tell it's it's
so inspiring the car is very it sounds
funny and by the way Meg put these up
something to break up walls otherwise
it's just a white wall just a white room
with Windows which are not which are
nice but sterile very sterile but I like
to start from a sterile place you know
before I get things dirty
[Laughter]
it forces you to go somewhere else in
your mind and that is your imagination
and that's where stories come from yes
it is he's right he's right tell me
about what happened
well
[Music]
we had a lot of fun we were having a lot
of fun um I I don't remember exactly how
specific and extensive the break was but
I do remember
that it came to us very very quickly and
we had a draft an entire draft of the
episode Done by the end of the first day
of writing with it which is outrageous
um it just happened very very quickly
and I don't even think we changed that
much we always you know we went back
through it and we because it only taken
us a day we were like let's just take
another day and go back through it make
sure that everything's as good as it can
be but it just flowed really yeah you
can tell like watching it and
my favorite thing is when we're writing
and you hit you hit that thing where the
writing is actually
doing the braking for you so like you've
done some breaking but you're coming up
with things and how you execute a scene
that you're like oh we'll we'll actually
pay this off later so things that I
imagine weren't in there
as as we were like writing it I I
remember these kind of things coming up
like probably like the p in the window
of joke and stuff like that but yeah do
you remember do you guys remember where
the all the fruit stuff came from of the
Scott martyr yeah yeah so our writer
Scott martyr yeah discovering that he
yeah it never had a blueberry never
eaten a blueberry and yeah we just
couldn't believe that a person had never
tasted a blueberry and that was just the
beginning then we really got into
listing all the things that he had never
eaten and an apricot a pair and it
wasn't just fruit specific vegetables it
was other like certain kind like a
chicken sandwich it was very very common
foods like extremely common foods not
rare foods not exotic foods very common
foods yeah and he had not had a number
of them it wasn't you know it's very
it's it's one thing when somebody's
like I don't yeah I know it's weird but
I don't like blueberries okay I get that
a little weird blueberries are delicious
never tried it never even tried one
never tried them but every once in a
while he'd bring in like smelling salts
and he'd be like let's do these today
yeah sure and then he'd smell those how
do you get that far in life without
trying a blueberry well you know that'll
be a question for when we do the martyrs
yeah let's say that for what was he's
not here today right he's not here today
but they have agreed that they will
remember
oh thanks oh you are going to Dane us
with your presence oh will you all right
The Writer's room with them like uh
Roselle and I talked for an extensive
period of time about nitrous the other
day which was fun sure because I was
gonna go get some for like a little
outpatient procedure and he was like oh
yeah whatever did you have the nitrous
yeah I did and I thought it wasn't as
good as I thought it was going to be I
thought it was going to be strong and it
was fine yeah they were like it feels
like a warm blanket kind of like come
like kind of sitting and it was good but
I don't think it had the strength of the
kind that Roselle was talking about
which is when you just Huff off of a
yeah like I have a balloon parking lot
and then you you basically go brain dead
for 30. and then you know everything
just goes
you fall down and right and he's like
yeah that's what it is that's what I
remember I remember there always being
this
the sound of your brain dying a little
bit it's the sound of the blood trying
to
um but yeah it wasn't as good but you
know it's because it was administered to
me by a doctor and not a whipped
who had the cracker yes do you remember
that was the thing that actually got
into the nitrous was the crap was the
cracking tool oh yeah
then you didn't do whippets no I did
whip it I did whip it oh oh the big you
did the big night I did yeah we had we
had well you know you could buy the
individuals
it was almost like The Keg tap whoever
had the cracker is the person who had
the the tap that was the that was the
the tool that would allow you to crack
the thing open and then fill up a
balloon and it was just another 15 year
old it just who was in charge of the
cracker I just now that I've got kids I
just don't
want to think about that for my kids I
I'm happy to say I probably only did I
could probably count on two hands the
number of times I actually did it maybe
three hands uh
uh sure but you hit a certain point
where you realize okay I'm gonna stop
doing that because I I truly believe I
don't even love The Sensation that it's
not that great I'm just gonna experiment
with it then I realize I'm actually
killing myself and then there were the
kids were like I'm gonna do this every
day and then you realize well they're
gonna do lots of things every day
speaking of things that make you pass
out from the episode I did notice on
this free watch a very funny Choice by
Charlie for when you guys like the
wicker chairs on fire and it like gasses
you in the in the trailer and they you
open other thing and Charlie is just
face this down we were laughing about
that yeah like yeah funny he made the
choice to to just lie face to face
directly face down arms at his sides
backwards as if you just like yeah we've
always enjoyed that kind of fall where
so you get knocked out instantly and
your arms are not you don't even stop
yourself your arm's just at yourself I
remember wanting to do it in a way that
it was like it's seemed really
believable that he made no effort to
stop himself yeah yeah but also I
remember being like you know you gotta
wait for a good chunk of dialogue before
they open the thing just be like this is
uncomfortable
oh yeah yeah straight down knowing it
would be funny Billy but it'll be a good
bit the biggest laugh for me in that
whole episode is the Hibachi Grill legs
kicking up and sliding out like I'm
proud of the the joke like the writing
of the joke but I'm really proud of the
special effects team that's a pretty
sweet duct tape rig you got going on the
door man yeah you like that tape the
chairs down too so don't slide know but
you stopped at the grill and that's got
me confused ran out of tape actually all
right it's not gonna slide through the
crack it won't because I measured the
crack and the crack is smaller than the
height of the grill we are all hooked up
here dude
a shot got a beer that'll come a nurse
it sure will
do you remember how hard it was for that
to happen no oh oh my gosh yeah we had
to get filament to pull the the legs
sideways and then have someone pull it
straight out now but at the time we were
very very frustrated and we had a we had
a great special effects team but for
some reason this was the one that
stumped them because you had to get the
timing exactly right so I remember
exactly how this happened because you
guys were in the oh in the van sorry
also yes you know what I do remember
also the time this maybe was what you're
talking about when you say timing
because it wasn't like when to do it it
was starting it slow and then speeding
it up yeah it's like do we yank it out
it's like no yes do we do it all slow no
you start slow and you it's like again
it hits a bump so it's gonna go boom and
then the legs happen and then the legs
have to collapse and the legs have to
collapse at the same time it can't go
one one it just doesn't look as funny
it's Gotta Go Bump Bump and then out and
then and so so we're we're thinking well
we're in Hollywood but we know that at
this Point our show's a piece of [__]
and and we don't have any money so we
got to figure out now again we've seen
dinosaurs on screen in 1993 and yet we
can't just get this goddamn Hibachi
Grill to just do what we needed to do
they wound up having two three two
special effects guys one on one side of
the trailer one on the other
they cut a hole through the through the
van and they pulled the string this way
and then a third special effects guy
that pulled the thing out that's right
and you know why because the van the the
tightness of the van is such that we
couldn't put two guys in there to pull
on the strings to have the legs come out
so we had to like drill through the
outside the U-Haul and originally what
they did was they fed the wire this way
right and then through a little like
snake hole out so the time the way that
they had without drilling a hole so all
three guys were on the other side of the
truck and pulling but how do you get the
timing right where the the attention
isn't this way the tension is this way
but then eventually it's got a pull like
through a pulley system but it's also it
was so complicated there's so many
different ways until they got it until
they got it thank God we spent the time
on it because it's yeah it's like it
definitely works yeah yeah you wouldn't
think that it would be that difficult
but it's also like because we have a
very specific
sort of like timing in mind of what we
want to happen it's like as you said
it's got a fault both legs have to
collapse first and then there's going to
be like the tiniest microbeat and then
it just yeah you know what I mean and
you guys have such a funny reaction it's
just like
staring at it yeah yeah
there's sort of there's the air of like
yeah that was we could have seen that
coming maybe I loved it I love the the
attitudes throughout the entire episode
it's always fun when characters are on
the same page or excited and happy and
having fun so Dennis and Frank when they
first get back there how excited they
are and how on board they are and
there's very little fighting there's
very little argument it's more they
might have a little disagreement but
Dennis is up for anything and Frank's up
for anything that's fun same thing when
Charlie got back there as well
everybody's excited playing those colors
as Dennis I miss
like playing the you know the the like
you know still calm and still everything
but and still kind of narcissistic and
full of himself but like I don't know
not always angry
it's a simple story there's no big theme
we're trying to jam in there there's no
like well it's they're on a road trip
but it's really about uh you know we're
really saying it's about XYZ no they're
trying to go on a road trip and they're
unable to pull it off and that's it so
it allows for those grounded moments
because people can relate to it right we
don't have to we don't have to sort of
invent a motive for why people would
want to go on a road trip like people go
on a road trips so yeah so then then we
have nothing but free reign to then be
like okay well what are the funny things
that happen that keep them from going on
this road trip yeah so yeah it doesn't
it wouldn't make sense to have any like
heightened Hearts one person that we've
talked about on the podcast in the past
um and now people can put a face to his
name is Cha-Cha so Cha-Cha who we've
mentioned in the podcast was Danny's
friend
um who may or may not have been hang on
certain organization that may or may not
have existed somewhere in the Northeast
part of this country we can't say for
sure but we were
it could be that he possibly was a
member of one of those or types of the
American Legion like yeah yeah or
whatever the Carpenters Union something
I didn't say [__]
now the thing is that Cha-Cha has since
passed so we're we're clear to talk
about in in many different ways but none
of the ways that will get us beaten up
or murdered ideally Cha-Cha was the best
he was the he was so he was he a boxing
promoter for Tony Danza and that's how
Danny met him yes yeah Cha-Cha and I had
a night where he took me to a um a fight
at Madison Square Garden yeah what was
this
around that time I guess I was in New
York City and oh it was I don't know it
was something like we were shooting in
Philly and then there was a big fight
coming up at Madison Square Garden and I
was talking to Cha about it I think it
may have been even been when we were
doing that episode
and he was like yeah he was like I get I
could get a synth that I fight you know
and I was like let's do it you know what
I mean so I went to New York and I
stayed in New York and I went to his he
had a he had a a coffee like a cafe
Mulberry Street called Mulberry Street
yeah yeah Little Italy yeah it's like a
July yeah it was gelato it had pizza it
had lots of things yeah lots of stuff
yeah yeah yeah I had had coffee it had
calzones whatever you wanted you could
get there and everybody knew Cha-Cha
everybody everybody knew cha and so you
know he I went there and I met him there
you know he he fed me gave me some
espresso then we went to the fight
together and uh had a blast and you know
everybody at the stadium knew him like
everybody you know and uh we just we
just had a really really fun night and I
think very fondly on Cha-Cha because he
really he really like hosted that night
it was and it was it was really cool
those scenes down in the Italian market
are like they feel very alive there's a
lot of pedestrians and you know we
didn't like pay for like 200 ushers that
day we were just filming down in the
market and you know I'm sure we had like
15 or 20 people maybe we you know had
them cross through that wasn't the
Italian market to be clear yeah in
Philly yeah but like we that was still
at a time where I think we could shoot
and we wouldn't draw a huge crowd right
yeah 2000 yeah season five not yet yeah
we could still get away with it although
I do remember people yelling to Danny
when we were driving around the clock
yes but when we hit the guy with the
with the by the way the stunt guy nailed
it going over the uh yeah sure did and
we'll start we'll start that from the
beginning because that was a really fun
moment in the shooting of the show that
we reference a lot because it was very
specific we were going around a big loop
so when we were shooting we would just
because I had to throw it at that guy's
head and I think I missed like three
times but we had to do this giant loop
around this one neighborhood in Philly
where we would just go up and down the
street and the car is being towed right
so the car is not really driving it's uh
yeah right and so we have a camera car
shooting us and then and so we're just
going around we're passing the same
houses and the same people and no one
knew our show including people in
Philadelphia but everybody knows Danny
so the neighbors were out on their
Stoops and every time we would pass by
they would yell out hey Danny hey Danny
come on over Danny I'll make you some
ziti and then we'd be passing and turn
around we'd come back around and then
just more and more people Danny yeah and
we had a joke running joke in the car
about it getting more extreme like oh
Danny come over and let me tie you up in
the basement
me wear your face then
a spike off the foot come here Danny
Danny just a little piece of your body
for the basement for the trophy room
Danny Danny I'll bake you into a city
Daddy can we eat you for dinner tonight
Daddy
yeah yeah everybody wanted a piece
everybody a piece of Danny they wanted a
piece you know who could blame him who
could blame him and then uh and then
also if you remember from that shoot
um one of the trucks got hit by
lightning
one of our camera trucks got hit by like
no I don't remember that oh yeah we were
shooting down there there was a
thunderstorm a lightning storm out of
nowhere I remember it's a huge
thunderstorm yeah and you don't really
know where to go because we don't have a
set so the neighbors were like you can
come into our house
with the lights yeah we go up into these
truck these giant Metal Trucks which of
course are grounded from the tires but
still it's terrifying and like the
trailer is like shaking and whatnot and
then one of our trucks got hit by hit by
lightning Jesus what happened did it
like blow up or like no
maybe that's why this episode is so good
because it's like infused with the power
of my lightning it's infused for the
power of Zeus right the power of Zeus
came through us
um a lot of Philly stuff yeah you did
you shoot this entire other than the the
scenes in the bar and in front of the
bar did you shoot all of it in Philly
the gas station scenes and stuff yeah
that was in LA uh not far I believe not
far from the Patty set
in downtown yeah like
could really pass for Philly because it
was just very Urban and yeah
and chases you guys like that yeah that
was downtown yeah and I wonder because
we haven't been shot down there a while
like the more and more we go down in the
neighborhood it's nicer and nicer it's
nicer we can't even nicer we can't even
shoot outside of that Paddy set very
much anymore because it's I went from
judgment night to like you know hipster
hipster night do you remember like in
the early years where whatever that we
might have talked about this in the
podcast the guys across the street oh
yeah would just lay on their like car
horn when we were filming and our line
producer had to go over and just give
them cash it was just uh they were just
it was just a Shakedown I kind of see
both sides of that yeah sure I mean they
were shooting on my street like two
weeks ago and I pulled up and they're
like you can't go up there and I was
like no I live up there and they're like
sorry you can't go through and I was
like I'm sorry you're telling me I can't
go to my house and they're like yeah
they're filming and I was like I'm gonna
drive and if you get in front of my car
I'm gonna run you over like what the
[__] and of course it's like some poor
PA yeah yeah some ideas the first day on
the job like I was told not to let
anyone up the street I don't really want
to work in TV and uh totally but like
the guys the guys uh across the street
from us they had a business and we would
just shut the street down or we would do
like intermittently they had a business
like Cha-Cha had a business
cars come in cars go out whose cars they
are I don't know but the horns [__]
work so give me cash but that one time
in particular I remember and they were
started they started to blare music out
of their cars and it was because the
they were told that they couldn't bring
they had some importing exporting
business somebody told them they
couldn't bring their trucks in yeah and
they were like this is our business you
just you can't shut down the street
unless you pass and so we paid them yeah
I see it from their perspective yeah
yeah yeah it's a middle I think what
you're saying is there's a middle ground
in that case there is a middle ground
there is a middle ground
[Music]
all right who here hates cooking oh God
thank you overrated it's just it's it's
so much time and energy hours of
shopping and prep and cooking and
cleaning also it's just not economical
well check it out Charlie we're
sponsored by Factor America's number one
ready to eat meal kit they shipped fresh
nutritious meals made with high protein
I love that I love protein guys big
protein guy I love Factor especially the
Protein Plus meals because they are
extra filling and great for my busy days
where I want a quick and healthy meal
well that's a huge Boon when we're busy
on set you know we're just kicking off
production and there's hardly ever time
to fit a meal into your schedules well
we do have a caterer you're aware of
this right well yeah I mean you know but
the caterer he's not dietitian approved
factor is you know plus it only takes
two minutes to heat up versus trudging
over to the truck and you know waiting
in line yeah who's making you wait in
line well I'm not
I cut to the front but yeah yeah you
know but I'm saying in theory be like
Glenn don't let anyone stand in the way
of your meal time ever again head to
factormeals.com
sunny50 and use code sunny50 to get 50
off your first box so that's code
sunny50 at factormeals.com sunny50 to
get 50 off your first box
[Music]
I really got slapped in the face with
apple juice or something like that yeah
so you were feeling the actual your
frustration now that kid's got to be uh
62 63 years right now Shannon McCain
what's his name Shannon McCain Shannon
McCain what's he up to is he is he been
working on channel he's 38 years old wow
[Music]
so that means he was 24 when he did it
did the episode yeah yeah yeah well I
think runaway train was your pitch I
feel like maybe I remember like working
on that and like we might have had some
different song or something and I think
I wasn't in the break maybe it was maybe
the president you had in the room
because I feel like you liked that song
I liked well I like that I remember that
song being on the summer of probably
1990 I'm gonna say
four sure the summer of 1994. that
sounds right that song was on constantly
and the video they would play the video
and it was all about like runaways and
then it became a whole marketing
campaign uh where they were talking
about how many lives the song saved
because people were The Runaways were
inspired to like call home or come home
this is like all engineered by MTV and I
thought man it just seemed like such a
scam to sell to sell records right as if
they're like kids on the street that
would hear that song and be like oh you
know what I'm the runaway train I'm the
runaway train back in touch with my my
family who's who's definitely looking
for me that's why I ran away in the
first place they're really um right
they're really that's the nuclear family
that I needed yeah I love that she's
like you need to hear the songs it's got
a message for you and then she cannot
remember the words it just delivers all
the emotion but a few of them I also
like that she she immediately invade is
like invading his space like she's she's
gotten drunk like so fast and she also
mimes like you get she starts moving
yeah as like before she reveals the piss
jar yeah she does a couple movements
which like on second viewing you're like
oh that was her zipping up yeah yeah
yeah
I got some meaning to hear about
a second
[Music]
[Applause]
I actually got this Uncle out there that
said
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's an open mouth jar yes like so
how did she
that's a bunch of dudes right now
Caitlyn just figure it out I don't know
it's a good good aim
I wonder how many of her cars we wrecked
so we wrecked the the first the blue one
and mac and Charlie died and then this
one gets stolen and then we we wrecked
the one at the mcpoyle wedding Massacre
I drive it into the pole I think it's a
purple PT Cruiser yeah yep
um what do you remember anything else
about the writing of this episode uh
Charles nope me either
um you guys do you know did you have all
that what I like about it is that
there's just the Simplicity in just
mixing up the pairings like somebody
goes back into the back and then
somebody moves to the front seat and
like that kind of energy of the story is
just really funny okay yeah yeah uh but
was that planned or did you guys just be
like generally they're gonna be on a
road trip I mean I think so that's so
long ago it's really hard to remember
yeah it's hard to remember I mean I
don't think we would have gone into
writing it without there being I don't
think we broke them in the detail that
we break the stories now like sometimes
we did and sometimes we didn't sometimes
we're like they go on the road trip this
happens they go to the farmer's market
we do the blueberry run the car gets
stolen you know like
um I think you improv improved on that
on the day possibly I mean I remember
Roselle pitching the sheriff of patties
okay so that was probably the show right
because the guy's back in the last scene
yeah so but I think the ocular pat down
think joke I'm pretty sure you came up
with though
yeah I didn't knock your path down and I
cleared him I'm sorry I'm saying that I
did an ocular assessment of the
situation garnered that he was not a
security risk and I cleared him for
Passage
what are you talking about I'm talking
about breaking down the security
situation clearing an individual and
making it safe for Passage
foreign
how exactly do you view yourself
within the context of our group
the sheriff of patties well I can't I
can't have this conversation
I want to unfold this thing I'm going to
pass out but my favorite part of that
whole thing was is setting that up and
then in the end finding out that Charlie
is also very much aware of the process
and and he he's clear to him I thought
yeah he's
the funny reveal that we've had these
conversations many times yeah yeah yeah
I also liked the little round about the
glaze on the chairs yeah
I don't remember how we did I
did I smoke machine in there I don't
remember how we did that yeah I think it
was just I think it was just that I
don't think it was anything more
complicated than that thank God we
didn't have to actually set anything on
fire because they they send the whole
fire department when you do that [__]
light candle these days on set and the
whole fire department's got to shut I
tried to cook my husband dinner on
Friday and the fire department Carl
called
shut off an alarm I did I sent off our
own fire alarms and apparently we have
uh we have it's somehow connected to
like the security alarm and then they
they called us and the fire department
called and so two very embarrassing
conversations my husband just had to be
like no my wife's just cooking yeah it
doesn't happen very often that's
probably why we haven't been so they
actually came by now no no they just oh
they did okay all right well so I had an
experience uh I don't know maybe about a
year ago and we were we had like a
busted pipe in our Landscaping
and we had like expanded our Landscaping
so
I knew where the Landscaping uh the the
controls were for turning off all the
water that goes to the Landscaping
except there's this like a new section
of landscaping that had been done and it
wasn't on the same pipe so I was like I
don't know how to stop this and there's
[__] water geysering
so we had to call we had to call uh I
don't know if we called I guess we've
called the fire department or somebody
yeah I don't know yeah I guess we did
but they they show you know we were just
like just like why do you always have to
show up on a fire truck like you know
it's like it's like midnight you know
like the whole waking the whole neighbor
a neighborhood up the siren got like
blaring honking the horn like lights
blowing up you know or let's say oh man
Spiderman
and I I these guys got out I uh there's
nothing more emasculating it's so
amazing hey bud you want us to turn your
water off for you yeah yeah yeah
basically wants to come in there and
take care of your wife too yeah you can
turn her up water on every single guy
was was like six foot three on average
you know what I mean like no one was
below six foot three it was like six
foot three and above every single guy
I'm not kidding you looked like he could
be a male model we got the calendar
shoot right after this so it looks like
it yeah I will say I noticed I noticed a
major difference when I first moved to
Los Angeles with the police force I
noticed the the LAPD and California
State uh the highway patrol those are
some big people and In-Shape people even
and even if the women aren't large they
seem like they're in very good shape and
all the cops I knew in New York and
Philly yeah fat as hell yeah not really
or skinny but like never like not in
like the kind of California shape where
yeah right these are California firemen
and yeah policemen right yeah yeah just
coming correct right just coming
straight from the gym like hitting the
gym at 4am every single morning you know
what I mean cooking cooking uh you know
sticking to a a paleo diet down there at
the at the firehouse right cooking
everybody chicken and vegetables let's
lay off the rice guys we're gaining a
few lbs when we show up to these
people's house we really got to make the
men feel small
that's our primary goal here right
putting out fires absolutely every time
if we can more important than that
though and pressing the woman in a
masculating demand that's why they
became firemen in the first place right
yep that's right I think you're
absolutely right stickers all the time
was that an improv on the day I can't
remember definitely
the whole thing
yeah it was pretty gross the stem and
then in the core you didn't tell me not
to eat the stem dude did you eat the
stickers that are all over it yeah it
was gross of course it's gross it's a
sticker buying stickers all the time
dude this whole thing is a disaster I
I'm going back to the car we thought
about that in the in the editing room
yes we did because you were we we both
were on the same page where you're like
uh I thought it was funny yeah because
you improv to I eat stickers all the
time and you were like that is the
dumbest thing I've ever heard we're now
we're establishing what does that mean
Charlie eats stickers all the time and
we're like yes okay good you guys
remember that too oh yeah yeah look I'll
fully admit that that there's they're
just and everybody's got a line right
everybody's got a line it's not like
that's earlier Seasons right so maybe
the characters aren't have gone as crazy
yet so you're you're still having the
conversation you know do or do they not
eat stickers you know by season six and
seven we know that Charlie and Frank and
possibly sometimes maybe Mac eat
stickers like sure create contracts and
all sorts yeah
pieces of a credit card wolfhare like
all inconclusive the line is always
changing and yeah and always but we just
had a conversation this morning I know
where Glenn was pointing something out
that was like I don't think this makes
any kind of rational sense and Charlie
and I are both like
yeah like there's part of me that just
like in those moments I want to back
down just because I I
I could just sense you guys being like
Oh no yeah but we didn't fight back
though no you didn't we didn't fight
backwards we were like okay okay
um let's let's see let's pivot let's see
if we can figure it out yeah because
there is a there is a tendency to want
to just be like
well come on man like we we do crazy
[__] all the time why is it this thing
but we each have one of those moments
throughout the week where you're like no
this is my line and we can either like
tell the person they're being stupid or
we can kind of figure out by the way I
usually like to be like
do you guys stand behind you fully stand
behind this and if you do and you guys
are like this is amazing I fully stand
behind it I still might fight back a
little bit but but I'll eventually just
be like all right I'm just gonna back
off yeah you know what I mean uh because
I don't feel like you do it that often
it's just every now and then yeah no no
no I mean it's like if the joke is
really funny
you know you probably get a little
insecurable
no you know what it is it's actually the
opposite it's when I'm like this if it's
really really funny I care less about
how ground grounded it is you know what
I mean if it's making me but that's my
but that's my me thinking something's
funnier or not funny you know whereas
you guys might find something funny that
I'm like I don't even think that so not
only is that not funny but it but it
also there's it's not grounded in any
sort of reality that I can believe yeah
that's it it's just a reality thing
right yeah it's a sticker thing for you
or the gun thing with Frank and the in
the episode where he's shooting in that
thing we're like it's just not that
funny to me so I'm like why are we
bending reality for some but it's funny
to you guys and it's funny to a lot of
people in the audience so it's like okay
it is what it is what about now is the
sticker thing funny to do now no she
found it no not that funny but I can
appreciate why I I understand why other
people think it's funny uh I just
don't think it's that funny I mean I
think you know buy that the guy would
eat stickers all the time no I buy that
you would have eaten the sticker on the
pear and that that it tasted awful and
that you ate the stem and the seeds and
all that kind of [__] because you don't
know how to eat a pear like I somehow
that's okay with me but this is the ones
that passes it's the one step past where
you say like I eat stickers all the time
that means that means you're a man who
looks at a sticker and goes I'm gonna
eat that yeah probably just like a
scratch and sniff sticker but yeah
it's so good so that additional line
would have brought it back for you if he
was like what are you talking about like
you scratch you sniff you taste you
scratch yourself it's like it's just
scratch and sniff yeah since when it's
scratched them today scratch it if it
taste the ones on the bananas do taste
like bananas
um have you guys ever been to the Grand
Canyon
uh did road trip once with our dog many
years ago our first dog Arthur and uh
it was two degrees when we got to the
Grand Canyon and Arthur had to take a
crap and I remember like the steam
coming up like he was just like squeeze
one out took a dump at the Grand Canyon
we stayed like a Red Roof Inn
yeah the old days the old days right I
looked at it it was like this is really
sad but looked at it was like yeah sure
oh really yeah I think because I'd seen
things in books accident on television
so many times yes what is it impressive
of course but there's something about
this world that we live in now that you
have access to things so much you're
like I imagine seeing that for the first
time when you're riding a horse across
the country and you're like oh [__] oh
yeah we got a home a big hole a big hole
could be the end of the world not sure
yes this is where the world is it is
strange because I've flown over it so
many times because that is the direct
route back to the east coast and so you
look at it from the sky and of course
it's it's impressive it's a massive
Gorge but because of the scale because
of the height yeah you're like you can't
really get a sense of it because so I'm
kind of like nah I get it yeah I had the
exact opposite reaction uh I did not I
actually expected maybe because my
expectations were low I fully expected
to not be impressed by it because it's
seen so many pictures of it right I'm
like well I mean I just it's not it's a
[__] hole in the ground like it gives
a [__] uh but you know whatever it was
we were on a road trip my girlfriend and
I at the time is the early 2000s and we
just we were like let's stop by the
Grand Canyon great went to the Grand we
went to like this one area where you
could really like stand like really
close to the edge and um which is maybe
a lot of it
but I was absolutely floored to me it
gave me the feeling of being like Oh I'm
so small and insignificant in a way that
actually is like kind of great and yeah
I found it really yeah I felt the same
there was a space to that for me where
you see like how many galaxies there are
and you're like wait wait we're one dot
and one of these things like I find that
comforting but the Grand Canyon I was
like oh it's nice
all right
[Applause]
we interrupt this podcast to talk about
Mech your favorite subject boners
you know what Bluetooth is
to the Bluetooth train Bluetooth is an
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
in chewable form at a fraction of the
cost and now they also have vardenophil
mint flavored chewables with the active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson so
you can stay hard and fresh
[Applause]
so no more having your partner tell you
tastes like boner pills Bluetooth
tablets are uh performance enhancement
for the bedroom and can help men gain
extra confidence when it's time to
perform hey you know what else what it's
simple and affordable so even while
prices continue to rise so can your mag
penis
if you don't think you need it you
haven't tried it and here's a special
deal for you listeners try Bluetooth
free when you use our promo code sunny
at the checkout just pay five dollars
shipping and get those free boner pills
man that's bluetooth.com promo code
Sunny to receive your first month for
free
foreign
thought we'd get through one of these
without hearing from athletic greens
well you've got donkey brains that's
right because we are once again
supported by athletic greens and their
delicious green powder ag-1 with one
scoop of ag1 you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals Whole Food
Source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens keyword
absorbing right not every multivitamin
gives you so many important nutrients
that your body can actually absorb so
absorbing everything it can is a good
thing oh yeah no it's good it's good my
body's working at 100 efficiency yeah my
body is absorbing every single nutrient
and not wasting a single thing your body
is taking its job very seriously as my
body's doing its job like it never has
done it before you know plus ag-1
supports Muscle Recovery and better
sleep quality which is a big reason I
take it every day it also has less than
one gram of sugar no GMOs or nasty
chemicals and no artificial anything
because spoiler alert you don't want to
be absorbing that go green instead with
athletic greens to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com sunny
again that is athletic greens.com Sunny
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance
foreign
[Music]
have you guys ever hitchhiked and or
picked up a hitchhiker before yes yeah
which one no I don't know I think for me
in in New Jersey hitchhiking in New
Jersey like you don't know you pick one
up or you were hitchhiking many times
yeah I have but not like a not like a
hobo across the country you know like
Jersey Shore towns like in Shore towns
where people are just going back and
forth to different like vacation spots
to people will be hitchhike all the time
okay I finished like many many times I
mean through like entire Summers back
and forth and how many people did you uh
did you rob how many people did you just
zero uh I hadn't I had I had zero
negative I got into a car accident one
time with somebody who was who who I was
I had hitched a ride with somebody who
had been drinking and I should have said
maybe I'll get out of this one I didn't
and I we got an accident any of these
people they try to talk you into putting
your mouth on them I I would have done
it I mean sure time at the time I would
have done it now is that because you
just were so appreciative of them giving
you a ride and you were like well the
least I can do is get my mouth on you
I'm just I was trying to get my mouth on
anything I could I was anything well not
a dick but that just wasn't my thing but
like yeah I guess I'm sorry you said you
would have done it I'm thinking I'm not
anymore
no I was picturing a man so
interestingly enough I didn't even go
there I went right to a woman a young
woman asking me to put my mouth on her
for a ride and that's never happened in
the history of human history right I
think it's going to be a man that's
going to be doing that yeah I just if I
ran into Sizemore maybe but other than
that I'm sorry
there's so many moments in this episode
that that had me chuckling
um I'm trying to remember trying to name
the states I thought was very funny
saying East Virginia and West Virginia
and North Virginia and all the some
little things from my well that
that the East Virginia West Virginia
North Virginia came from a thing that I
swear to God I was like 25 or 28 no 23
and I was in New York and I was looking
at a map of the United States and I was
looking at West Virginia
and it was like as if someone had told
me there was like a West California I
was like I just kind of I'd forgotten
about West Virginia I just just because
like I'm like what sports teams are like
you don't you don't hear about it
there's a chunk of my life from like
fifth grade when you learned the states
to my adulthood where I'd I'd forgotten
about West Virginia uh so I think that
like that state thing was going in there
like make fun of that also like the her
opting out for the cheaper uh radio
situation was something that my parents
had done in my childhood oh yeah which I
think I've said on this were they yes I
had a Honda yeah Accord 1980 well they
had a Honda Accord 1985 with no radio
yeah just a little plastic plate that
said Honda because it was cheaper to get
the option with no so not even not a CD
player not a tape deck no radio no radio
man so I would ride around with a
Boombox hey yeah well I think music is
distracting when you're driving and
therefore dangerous yeah also like they
didn't like listen to like pop music
like occasionally like you're throwing a
classical station
yeah right like some NPR the news it was
usually the news was on or someone would
sit at a piano and be like trying to
like knuckle out of it's fine piece I
look at your parents and they look like
the physical embodiment of NPR
[Laughter]
yeah
like the NPR in human form yeah just
a theory people but not like not like
rock and roll
people so uh yeah so like you know my
mom just teaching music class from
kindergarten to eighth grade my dad is
teaching at the local college and yeah
music everywhere but right not in the
car but I got music in the car so in
high school my buddy uh Sean Coulter had
a male Jeep and he had he had put a a
radio in there that he'd sort of put in
himself and the radio had a brand name
it was called the spark-o-matic now I
bought the spark-o-matic off a Coulter
and put it in my car where I had it
didn't quite fit so you had to put like
little pieces of wood in there just to
kind of like get it to stay in sweet and
it worked went to had it for like two
weeks went to one Motel Six party
the Sparkman
oh the spark Ematic of all things oh man
I think that the absence of that the
hole that it left behind led to your
hatred of holes and why you were
impressed by the grace
tie it all together yeah
um one thing I I did uh pick up on that
I remembered in the conceiving of or the
writing of the episode I don't remember
where it came if it was in the break or
if it just came when we were writing it
was the French Press getting the French
Press at the Italian market because that
came from a very specific
um I did a road trip from Alabama to Los
Angeles I uh my high school car kind of
died on me and so I went back to Alabama
and I bought my my mom's car like an old
Lexus ES I was like you know driving
across the country you gotta have you
gotta have coffee right but the coffee
like gas this is before there was a
Starbucks set different exits right so
the coffee you could really only get
coffee at like gas stations and stuff
like that
so I was like I'm gonna buy I'm gonna
bring my own coffee grounds and bring
like just a little personal French press
and I'll stop at the gas station I'll
fill up I'll go inside and I'll ask
where the hot water is you know for tea
and stuff and I would just go in the gas
station and I would put my own coffee in
the French press and I would fill it
with water excuse me where's your hot
water for tea you know a glenius gland
[__] I've ever heard and yet it makes
absolute sense it does it's definitely
the thing that I would make and at the
time did make fun of you for and would
still make fun of you for but also would
love I would love to enjoy a couple of
that well exactly so it makes sense yeah
yeah it's just so particular but it also
is fantastic yes no it is very it is
very very Glenn you're absolutely right
adding as many steps to my life as
possible you know what I mean like Rob
would have just sucked somebody off for
a better cup of coffee
would have let the guy drink an espresso
and then suck this guy and got the
caffeine that way that's when uh it
shows at his best like everyone's
bringing stuff from their own lives and
you know you get Martyrs blueberry story
and like just every little thing's going
in there and then do we do that anymore
is there anything any piece of art that
is the fear right the longer you're in
the business that you're like uh do I
live enough of a life too well yes I've
thought about this a lot right to it and
I'm like I need to just like take a year
off and just like live like refill you
know have stories to tell I don't have
you know if you're working all the time
you run out of stories to tell them we
very typically go what do people do like
that question comes up now what do
people do what's the thing that people
do
especially if you've been working
together for so long you already know
what everybody's parents did to [__]
them up and that's what every writer's
room is anyway is like people trying to
like mine their their history and try to
figure out who they are and why they are
like that and then put it like imbue it
into the characters we've already we
already know I don't know all the
secrets yeah yeah I know all the secrets
yeah oh boy they've already gone to the
shop oh boy do you guys have any travel
destinations still on your bucket list
you'd like to see before you die
I want to go to Africa I've never been
to Africa yeah I'd love to go to Egypt
yeah I would like to go to Egypt so
definitely I want to see the pyramids
before I die for sure I have a million
play I want to go everywhere just
uh not right now
yeah but at some point
at some point well the next trip we're
taking is just right across the way to
the stages where you guys are going to
live for the next we walked into the bar
uh today and every season
since like five or six I get a crazy
sensation walking into that bar where it
feels like your home and it feels like
this place that you've lived in that
in a weird way you also are the
character even though you're you I know
this sounds psychotic but like
you've worked there for a long time yeah
and if you you click into something
immediately stepping on that stage maybe
that's part of what you're talking about
like you step onto the stage and you
start to feel like you're becoming the
character again a little bit and you
feel the history of how many years we've
been working on that
stay that's set and in that bar there's
also still the excitement especially in
the very beginning where everything's
still being put together and all the
electricians are there and the
construction people are there and props
are there and wardrobe is there and the
ads are there there's an energy to it
it's all coming yeah it's that but it's
to me it's like the floor and the bar
and the space and certain little
triggers like that yeah it takes me all
the way back to the herald examiner
where we kind of found the location and
started you know working on the first
time to all the years that we've been
there yeah to this weird like other life
that I've lived where it's like I've
been I've had a life but I've also been
this person for a long time yeah yeah
man it's sweet I love it you know it's
like uh well you could really see the
dust in the air though couldn't you do
you guys see that you guys pick up on
that I I that's course where my my my
brain goes too Dusty I walked on the
stage and I was just like what am I
breathing what am I breathing that was
my first thought your first thought was
like oh you know there's so much history
here it's such a more it's a much more
healthy thought well you know I feel
that way about movie sets the way you
feel about the Grand Canyon
uh the magic is there for you on a movie
the Magic's there for me in a false
reality so
is it better I don't know I'm not sure I
looked at the Grand Canyon I saw a lot
of dust
[Laughter]
[Music]